For the rest of this, and next, and
next, we're going to be talking about
discriminative methods for
doing recognition or classification.
By the way, I'll probably use those
words interchangeably, classification,
recognition.
Probably a little sloppy of me
because we talked a little bit about
the difference.
I'm just basically talking about
classifying something as being
an A or a B.
Or even more precisely, an A or a not-A.
Before we go forward, we're going to
make some assumptions, okay?
Our first assumption.
We're going to assume that there's
a fixed number of known classes, right?
So I'm going to tell you,
there are four things in this
universe you have to worry about.
Now, they might be As, Bs,
Cs, and none of the above.
But it's not like later I'm
going to give you some Ds or
later I'm going to give you some Es.
No, I'm going to tell you
the classes that exist a priori.
So when I train this system and
I'm defining the boundaries, I'm only
worrying about the classes that you
tell me in advance that I know about.
The other thing I'm going to assume
is that I've got plenty of data.
I've got training examples
that come from this class, and
it might not be,
shall we say, that data hard.
You know, I've got an exponential
amount, but I've got lots of data.
So it's possible for me to typically
find points that tend to be,
you know, might get confused
with some other class.
For the conversations we're going to
have today and the next time,
we're going to assume
an equal cost of mistakes.
So it costs you just as
much to call an A a not-A
as it does to call a not-A an A.
In fact,
one of the methods we'll talk about,
the fact that some of the distributions
might be quite asymmetric, right?
So you might be looking for,
say, I don't know, faces.
We're going to do that one.
In an image, you may know that most
places in an image, in most images,
are not faces.
So you might take advantage of that fact
in terms of how you search for them.
But we're not going to worry
about the relative cost.
Remember that loss function between
making the two kinds of mistakes.
And the other thing is,
that we're going to assume, is that,
and this is actually
good because it's true.
It's always good to assume true things.
We need to build a representation
of each instance.
So we're going to build a description.
But we don't know a priori
what features actually matter.
So we're going to write down a whole
bunch of things about each instance.
And then we're going to train a discri,
a discriminative classifier to make
the distinction, the the classification,
and it'll have to figure out where
the information is in the feature.
All right, so that's a lot of assuming,
but I'm good at making assumptions.